make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so I was sitting here thinking about
Avengers endgame and it actually tweeted
out this funny picture like Hasbro
moviegoers just like man like a ventures
in game really does seem bleak but it's
like well I mean but that's like not
even the worst of it though like but
here's okay here's the thing so so for
those of you guys who were like the
casual movie goer and Marvel Comics
you've got you've got some pretty dark
events and stories that take place right
like at the end of the day what was
Infinity Gauntlet really and finding
Gotham was more of like an action-packed
story than it was like a dark story
right I mean like half the lights of the
universe got snapped got snapped out of
existence but that was designed more to
show the power of Thanos than just like
how bad things got right I mean you
really found out how bad things got when
you found out that Adam warlock had
basically just like used all the
superheroes as cannon fodder as opposed
to them actually having a chance they
were designed to be a distraction so the
Silver Surfer could try to steal the
gauntlet off of Thanos which didn't work
here's one of the coolest things but in
terms of like how dark it can get y'all
haven't seen anything yet like if you
guys think adventures in game is dark
y'all haven't seen anything I mean
there's there's some dark stuff honestly
if I were a model and I wanted to do
like an exceedingly dark story I would
do they know separative the problem with
that is you have to do like a lot of
build up to it right like I mean and you
can even do like wharf Kings if you
wanted to but like yes that was
imperative I mean like that's the
cancerverse right like that's the
alternate universe where like no one
could die where you have like the mini
angled ones and all that kind of weird
stuff but it was basically a universe
okay so when Marvel Comics I know you I
love you guys know of Captain Marvel
like Harold Amber's before her before
her there was Marvel who was this guy
that was okay he wasn't really that
great of a character a lot of the really
old-school fans will tell you like he
was really really cool he was never cool
and so like there was basically Marvel
of the cream and he ended up dying of
cancer in like 1984 is the death of
Captain Marvel he was this graphic novel
written by jim Starlin it was really
really cool really interesting kind of
this nice send-off when Thanos like
escorted him to the realm of mistress of
death considering the two of them had
like always been enemies with each other
but what ended up happening is in the
cancer verse what Marvel did is he
brought all the superheroes together and
then using their combined power destroy
mistress death and so what it meant was
that nobody in that universe could die
because nobody could die they all
disputed up becoming like villains right
like the universe was just overrun with
life like it was just just super packed
it was it was kind of crazy you know
because I mean it was just essentially
like immortality but the Avengers ended
up becoming villains called The Revenge
errs and like it's kind of nuts I guess
it's kind of crazy
what is up happening at the end of that
story if Thanos brings mistress death
into the realm of the cancerverse
and ends up killing up Marvel which
basically like you know and like
introduces like an aspect of herself
back into that universe which
essentially like breathes death to like
the cancer or some people just end up
getting you know dying in different
things like that but the fact remains I
guess it's kind of a cool thing but more
so than that if what you're doing is
you're looking at the events of Avengers
in-game from a stance of like hope and
saying like well man things really don't
seem hopeful for the heroes no no cuz
they're gonna win right like I mean like
the events not playing out of such a way
where things seem hopeless it seems that
way but like it's not you want to talk
about a hopeless event like look at the
events of annihilation like annihilation
was nuts I mean it all really ended
because of Galactus like he's the only
reason the heroes won but dude
annihilation was nuts so what you have
in in Marvel Comics is you've got this
place called the negative zone but and
so like like if you have like all these
different universes right like an
infinite number of universes for an
infinite number of possibilities but
there's only one negative zone and each
universe can access the negative zone in
some form or fashion if they chose to
but the way it works in the negative
zone is you've got like you know
galaxies and solar systems and planets
and stars and all kinds of cool stuff
but you've also got a guy keen on a guy
called Annihilus who's who's like him
he's like an anthro gene or something
like that or in or throw Jan I came over
exactly how you pronounce it
but basically he's like this bud looking
guy the issue is that a nihilist was
afraid of death did the only thing he
was oh he was like Baltimore right like
the one thing he was afraid of was dying
so he was like he was like Baltimore
before Baltimore and winded up happening
is that he had this device called a
cosmic control rod which was basically
the negative zone equivalent of the
power cosmic
which is what Galactus has and so
realizing what the power cosmic was
Annihilus sought to to use it as a means
to like guarantee his immortality and so
using another guy here what his name was
but using another guy he basically like
pierced access through the through a
something called the crunch intellect
the main Marvel Universe and then
brought the annihilation wave which was
like this colossal like this this
astronomical army of like countless buds
and I say Thomas I mean like billions
and billions and billions of billions it
was enough to wear it like it spread
across the universe like a plank world
after wall after world felled the power
in the annihilation wave and when the
women I listened event picks up what you
basically got is like star-lord Peter
quill and and Richard Ryder Nova who
were leading in like the United
planetary front I think it is like au
UPF for some along those lines anyway
it's what's left of like those worlds
that haven't fallen and a literally the
universe is like in ragtags like pretty
much everything has been conquered like
stano's help denial Annihilus captured
Galactus and then like like basically
anomalous was like studying the power
cosmic
and like siphoning and off of Galactus
Silver Surfer is captured Frankie Rey
one of the heralds of Galactus was
captured I want to say Terrax was caffee
like all these super powerful beings
were captured by a nihilist literally
for the purpose of studying the power
cosmic
and then harnessing it and it was kind
of crazy because at the time that story
was going on
Marvel had Civil War so like Richard
Rider realizing like they need help
comes to earth that's where the most
powerful heroes are and it's like hey we
need your help and they're all fighting
over superhero registration so which is
like ok screw this he leaps he's like
you guys can't even get your own your
own crap together how could you possibly
help to save the universe so he just
ends up leaving but but like literally
like it's just like it's it's it's like
what's left of like a free universe is
in dire straits and like pretty much at
the at the brink of its total
destruction it ends up taking the
freeing of Galactus who annihilates 2/3
of the annihilation wave to basically
save everybody so like it's just kind of
mopping up after that but like it's
crazy how like everything that's going
on let everything that happens like it's
pretty bleak you know but but even if
you wanted to like move away from like
an interdimensional event and for I'm
sorry like a universal event and focus
on something that's still earthbound you
could do Shadowland
right like Shadowland was a story
there's written in 2010 a lot of people
don't like it I absolutely loved it
but Shadowland was a story written in
2010 that basically had this concept
called the beast and the Beast was this
this sort of demon entity that's a hand
worship right those of you guys who
follow daredevil on Netflix you have an
organization called the hand would you
like these super mystical ninjas from
Japan who can like resurrect people from
the dead and like you know do all kinds
of crazy stuff
anyway what is up happening is daredevil
is possessed by the Beast and then leads
the hand in New York and creates like
shadow land which is like this exactly
what it sounds like
this super like dark you know a screwed
up area and so basically it takes like
all these combined heroes so like
basically you know defeat like daredevil
and and it's kinda it's kind of nuts
because you're not getting this fight
between bullseye and daredevil where
bullseye takes out like 20 somebody
members of the hand and then faces off
against daredevil and hand-to-hand
combat but still like like I mean that's
really really dark in and of itself
you've got enemy of the state where
Wolverine is kidnapped by the hand and
Hydra working together and they
basically brainwashing and then send him
on a mission to kill all the superheroes
across the world there's a what-if story
where he successfully does I mean
there's there's all kinds of like really
really dark stories you could do war of
Kings was really dark and lovely really
dark it was pretty good but it wasn't
really dark what it was is you basically
had the Inhumans
who were leaving the Kree Empire due to
like kind of a battle over leadership
between lipoly and humans and I think it
was Ron in the accuser after Ron and
destroyed the supreme intelligence and
then you had a Vulcan who was a third
Somers brother who took over a race
called the Shiar and the two the two
went to war that's actually what created
the rift in space that led to the cancer
curse so like it's all these different
things that go on but you've got
anihilation conquest which was a sequel
to annihilation we're all Tron tries to
like conquer the universe
and almost does like there's a lot of
really really dark stories they can go
with and now that Marvel owns another
yeah Disney owns like Fox which means
they own like the x-men in the Fantastic
Four all those all kinds of dark stuff
that you can do Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four a story where you learn
about like all the tribes of the inhuman
cities you've got the war of the four
cities you've got like the the the like
the bleak future
you've got the mad Celestials and like
Franklin Richards coming from the future
to like save everything I mean you could
do like you could do the Dark Phoenix
and the Phoenix saga proper you could do
Nimrod all right so so here's the thing
Nimrod was really really cool I know a
lot of you guys saw the Days of Future
past x-men movie in the future of that
universe you have you know the signals
are created like this perfect version
this this perfect Sentinel called Nimrod
and Nimrod had like a multitude of
abilities right like it could
shape-shift and take on the form of
other people so it could be anybody and
you and you could pass a Nimrod on the
street and never know um it could sense
like you could literally and
a mutant analyzed what their power was
and analyzed their weakness and then use
that information to like take them down
to say nothing of like all the
information it has stored on like the
database of mutants right so like in no
storm is claustrophobic because that's
one of the weakness that was you know
kind of assigned to her or at least was
discovered by her just in her years of
being part of the next of the x-men and
so on and so forth and so like Nimrod
can use that against her Nimrod knows
that like you know Cyclops is optic
blasts are basically energy from another
dimension so like seal his eyes shut or
like shoot him in the face and blow his
head off I mean like there's a any
number of things that Nimrod could do
but like throw him into the into the
light into the events of the MC I mean
there's a lot of things that they could
do a lot of this would take a lot of
building up and one of the things the
MCU focuses on is just like quick fast
and in a hurry stories right so like
Infinity Gauntlet took ten years of
building but like everything that went
on with infinity war and innovators in
game was background stuff with like all
the main stories right like it wasn't
like everything led up to it in terms of
like they've been fighting nanos for ten
years and now Santos has the Infinity
Gauntlet like they've been you know
trying to keep him from getting it the
OS is basically him operating in the
background and now he had the Infinity
Gauntlet and then infinity war and then
in game took place so like you know it's
it's it's it depends on how they want to
do it but like yeah I mean there's their
stories where Doctor Strange became a
disciple of Dormammu he was a student of
Dormammu and like killed everybody in
the universe there's a story where Jean
Grey becomes the Dark Phoenix and then
stays crazy and then destroys the whole
universe in the process you've got
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers where the beyonders wipe out
everything in existence like literally
destroy the multiverse like there's
there's a lot of there's a lot of really
dark stories they can do so like
Avengers in game isn't even the worst of
it not by a mile
like not by a mile at all you I mean you
got like fury secret war I mean you've
got all kinds of like crazy things that
go on and Marvel Comics in terms of dark
stories so yeah I mean just kind of you
know if any of those kind of winged it
like any of those strike your fancy like
pose a comment and let me know like like
which one of those seemed that coolness
to you I may end up doing a story on
there doing videos on I have I have no
idea I know we're gonna do fee make some
Dark Phoenix saga z-- um but aside from
that I mean I'm kind of curious what you
all think anyway guys uh if you are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys sub button to become part of the
Rob
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you